[Música]
Bienvenidos a este especial sobre la
fronteras más transitadas en América
durante el año 2022 me refiero a la
frontera entre Colombia y Panamá a
través de la selva del Darién El Paso
Guatemala México y el borde entre México
y el sur de Estados Unidos América
Latina y el Caribe experimentaron una
movilidad humana sin precedentes marcada
por un número récord de desplazados
forzosos y otras personas en movimiento
desde Sudamérica y a través de
Centroamérica hacia la frontera sur de
Estados Unidos factores socioeconómicos
relacionados a la violencia el deterioro
de la situación de los Derechos Humanos
desigualdad discriminación entre otros
fueron las principales causas de la
migración desde estos distintos países
del continente en 2021 más de 133 mil
personas cruzaron el Darién para ir
hacia el norte La mayoría de
nacionalidad haitiana pero en 22 a
finales de octubre ya se había
sobrepasado esa cifra a más de 200.000
de los cuales
134.000 eran venezolanos un 70.1% del
total de migrantes según autoridades de
Panamá
entrevistamos a Roberto saldana un
venezolano que atravesó nueve países
para llegar a Estados Unidos partió de
ese Perú donde vivía desde hace seis
años en busca de un lugar con
estabilidad política y económica nos
contará su travesía a través de las tres
fronteras más difíciles que cruzó para
llegar a Estados Unidos entró a la selva
del Darién por carreto Panamá y estuvo
caminando durante dos días y medios con
los pies húmedos por el barrio Roberto
nos comentará un poco Cómo fue la
llegada al también llamado tapón del
Darién en Panamá una vez Los Coyotes lo
embarcaron en lancha de cenecus Colombia
se dividieron en varios grupos de 30 a
40 personas treinta y pico de personas
entonces vienen cada cada había un
indígena del jefe y le da unos
tiquecitos a uno con con tres guías
porque eso eran tres guías que nosotros
este que lo estaban ahí para la cuestión
del camino claro había mucha gente que
no estaba preparada para ese tipo de
situaciones ya yo me había preparado ya
yo me iba preparado ya anteriormente
a ese tipo de situaciones porque
hace años yo
Yo como te digo hice curso cuando era
joven ese curso de supervivencia hice
curso de protector de protección al
ambiente y esa cuestión es que uno dará
cinco días diez días en Campos y
cuestiones y tratando de sobrevivir
bueno porque se me hizo un poco fácil la
la
cuestión de la transición del del pero
siempre ayer pero que la gente no tenía
los conocimientos este gente que
llevaban de todo llevaban maquillaje
llevaban todo este gente que quería que
era un pingí no sé un paseo normal pero
cuando empezó el trayecto en realidad en
la mañana que empezamos a irnos con los
guía la primera parada que fue un río ya
la gente Estaba desesperada ya la gente
está empezada a desprenderse los bolsos
todo todo todo empezaron a desprenderse
de todo de los bolsos este de todo lo
que tenían que le salía pesado que ya
están cansados y fue una primera parada
unos métricos nada más ni siquiera
fueron unos kilómetros fueron unos
metros Qué fue lo más difícil de ese
trayecto del Darién
Bueno después de ahí vi una una señora
embarazada vi una muchacha con su tío tu
esposo entonces pues mira ayúdame por
favor porque en realidad no puedo eso
fue también una parte que me retrasó
porque yo como andaba solo no no yo dije
No yo no le voy a parar yo me voy solo
pero el corazón mío es muy demasiado
grande que tuve que llorar esa persona a
medida que uno va subiendo el charco se
hace más pesado
la subida son un poco más inclinadas yo
me senté al lado de dos muertos un señor
que estaba al lado al lado izquierdo y
otro señor que estaba sentado al lado
derecho uno que estaba acostado y el
otro señor estaba aquí al lado derecho
sentado ahí como si estuviera normal
puede como si estuvieras durmiendo y
cuando eh cuando la mosca y el olor se
se sabía que estaba muerto el trayecto
por toda Centroamérica una vez que los
migrantes salen de la selva continúa
siendo difícil normalmente el tránsito
por la región sigue en autobuses o se
convierte en un viaje masivo en
caravanas ambos en condiciones
complicadas el último país de
Centroamérica al que llegan es Guatemala
algunos migrantes entre ellos Roberto
denuncian que los cuerpos policiales y
militares les quitan el dinero que
llevan para la travesía uno de los pasos
para cruzar de Guatemala a México es el
río suchate allí los migrantes embarcan
en Balsas improvisadas usadas para el
transporte de mercancías
al otro lado en la entrada de México la
guardia fronteriza está desplegada para
contener el tránsito en Tapachula la
ciudad más cercana los que logran no ser
interceptados por las autoridades deben
solicitar un salvoconducto de al menos
30 días que les permite el libre
tránsito por México pero estos permisos
se demoran incluso meses hay Quienes se
quedan a trabajar para complementar el
dinero y pagar la documentación y los
pasajes según cifras de la oficina de
aduanas y protección fronteriza más de
uno punto siete millones en documentados
pasaron por la frontera Guatemala México
en el último año San Diego Yuma Nogales
El Paso Río Grande en Texas y golpás
Brownsville son los territorios
limítrofes de Estados Unidos que abarcan
más de 3100 kilómetros de Linderos con
México una frontera en la que se
levantan varios kilómetros en muros
fronterizo para evitar el paso irregular
de personas las autoridades e
inmigración estadounidenses llevaron a
cabo Dos punto treinta y ocho millones
de encuentros con migrantes durante 2022
que incluye aprensiones y expulsiones
algunos de ellos residentes este ingreso
de migrantes superó al 1.64 millones
ocurridos en 2020 desbordando las
capacidades de procesamiento la
infraestructura federal y las
comunidades fronterizas en esta última
travesía para pasar a Estados Unidos
853 personas murieron tratando de cruzar
sin documentos a la frontera en los
últimos 12 meses una cifra histórica
según datos internos de la patrulla
fronteriza y los números pueden llegar a
ser más altos A mediados de octubre el
gobierno de Joe biden aplicó el título
42 a los venezolanos que anteriormente
estaban exentos de la norma de salud
pública y miles comenzaron a ser
expulsados como opción para ellos Crea
una medida humanitaria donde 24.000
personas de esta nacionalidad pueden
entrar por la vía legal cumpliendo una
serie de requisitos nuestro invitado
Roberto ingresó a Estados Unidos antes
de que esta Norma entrara en vigor llegó
el 24 de julio y ahora nos cuenta cómo
fue su arribo al país destino un viaje
en el que asegura arriesgó su vida una
vez que yo fui a Yuma duré cuatro días
en Yuma eso esos son los centros de de
reclutamiento de retención que tiene la
migración Pero tú llegas a un sitio es
esa misma noche te registran y de ahí te
llevan a otros a una hora y media o una
hora a otro reclusorio duras ahí en ese
reclusorio con treinta cuarenta personas
de diferentes clases de países
tú das un tiempo ahí te vas otra vez al
centro de Yuma a otros al mismo centro
que está en Yuma van te vuelvan a
registrar van a otro centro después ahí
en ese centro dure dos días al terminar
eso al siguiente día en la mañana me
llevan otra vez a Yuma me dice señor
Roberto aquí me dieron papel a firmar
firme mi documento donde de aislamiento
este se filmé mis papeles mi cuestión
entonces me me llaman en la mañana ya y
me llevan a un refugio en lo mismo del
del migración nos llevan un refugio pero
ya con los documentos ya
pasado que uno ya está libre pues aquí
en Estados Unidos hasta que tenga su
proceso
Aunque Roberto logró entrar otros miles
de venezolanos esperan por lo que pasará
después el 21 de diciembre cuando se
levante oficialmente el título 42 tal
como lo ordenó un juez Federal
inmediatamente sea efectiva la medida ya
no se podrá enviar a los migrantes que
lleguen a Estados Unidos de manera
Exprés a México el departamento de
seguridad nacional estima que recibirá
entre 9.000 y 14.000 migrantes por día
Muchos de ellos que han estado esperando
durante meses o incluso años en
campamentos y refugios improvisados en
México
Tenemos también de invitado en el
programa a William splinder Vocero de
acnur para América Latina
Cuáles son los retos y los esfuerzos en
los países de acogida necesarios para
ayudar a estos migrantes que ya salieron
de sus países
los retos son muchos y ya hemos pasado
la fase inicial de emergencia en donde
las personas que llegaban ya los
migrantes necesitaban ayuda humanitaria
urgente no un lugar donde quedarse
comida medicina techo es esta fase ya la
hemos superado en gran medida pero ahora
estamos entrando en una fase en que se
requiere más apoyo precisamente a las
comunidades de los países que los
reciben porque las personas migrantes y
refugiados llegan en general a
lugares a
ciudades a sectores más grandes ciudades
que son los menos favorecidos y que
necesitan un apoyo estructural porque
estas personas que llegan necesitan a
que los niños necesitan ir a la escuela
las personas necesitan apoyo de salud
que las personas necesitan empleo
etcétera entonces es acá donde vemos
pero esa es de comunidades también
entonces necesitamos un apoyo más en el
desarrollo económico y social de estas
comunidades que favorece a las
comunidades de acogida y a los y a las
personas que están llegando qué
estimaciones tiene para el 2023 sobre el
flujo migratorio si los países de origen
de los migrantes sigue sin ofrecerles
estabilidad económica social y política
Bueno pues el panorama
por el momento nosotros pensamos que va
a continuar a ver movimientos en ese
sentido probablemente se intensifiquen y
se vuelvan más complejos al menos en el
corto plazo por eso es importante tratar
de apoyar a estas personas primero en
los países de origen
lograr crear condiciones para que esas
personas no tengan que salir de su país
en busca de protección o de una mejor
vida esto por eso el desarrollo integral
es importante en estos países luego en
los países de tránsito porque muchas
personas transitan a través de varios
países hay que ver si se puede encontrar
opciones para ellos para que se queden
acá para integrarlos apoyando a las
comunidades y finalmente los países de
destino que son Estados Unidos pero
también otros en la región hemos visto
otras personas los venezolanos por
ejemplo la mayoría van hacia otros
países de América Latina hacia Colombia
de chile Ecuador Perú Argentina Brasil
entonces
tratar de apoyar a estos países para que
puedan continuar ofreciendo una acogida
a los refugiados y a los migrantes
gracias a William splinder de acnur
gracias a nuestro invitado venezolano
que también estuvo hoy y gracias a
ustedes por sintonizar este especial
sobre las tres fronteras más transitadas
de América en 2022 siga con Franz 24 y
con France 24 punto com
[Música]